euer kopf ist ungefähr so 40 50 cm von
dem tatsächlichen paket entfernten meter
maximal erhörte jedes mucksmäuschen was
da drin ist so arg ortsschild fake ist
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
in dem wir uns heute wieder um die
besten videos auf youtube kümmern erst
mal vorneweg ich habe bei dem video
jetzt hier nicht so sicher ob ich das
noch machen sollte weil das ganze ding
vor 17 tagen hochgeladen wurde und vor
einer woche schon so die ganzen
kommentare dazu hoch kam es kann gut
sein dass ein paar von euch denken
nämlich noch ein video zu dem thema aber
ich hab jetzt einfach gerade richtig
lust dazu ein video zu machen und
youtuber zu sein ist generell aber so
einen balance akt zwischen was möchte
man selbst machen und was möchten die
leute sehen deswegen hoffe ich dass
nicht so viele von euch jetzt genervt
weil er war wirklich bock auf dieses
video habt denn es ist wieder einiges
schief gelaufen und zwar dreht sich
alles habt ihr schon am anfang gesehen
um lucy wir schauen mal hier das hier
ist gut sich kanal wir schauen uns das
ganze jetzt mal an was er so macht der
macht scheinbar blogs und er hat vor
zwei wochen dieses video ja gemacht ich
versende mich per post ich habe bis
jetzt nur 1 2 kommentare ich zu seinem
video gesehen aber eine sache die ich
bisher noch nicht gehört habe ist die
dass es diese videos ja irgendwo schon
mal gab nämlich haben wir jetzt hier
oben einfach mal ich meine irgendwas in
die richtung gab schon in amerika gucken
wir mal nach reis kann
er war doch irgendwas okay sie daran
mailbox network da hat sich jemand an
amerika schon vorher in einem paket
versendet vor einem monat 16 millionen
aufrufe dafür bekommt woher könnte
dieser youtuber die idee gehabt haben
alles in allem ist es ja nicht schlimm
wenn man sich inspiration aus amerika
holt weil wirklich wirklich viele trends
aus amerika so langsam auf deutschland
überschwappen das hat schon so oft
gesehen aber in dem fall finde ich
irgendwie komisch weil ich bereits das
video gesehen habe so armee massiv an
die box und dann drei wochen später
kommt genau das gleiche video in
deutschland es ist kein verbrechen aber
cool ist es halt auch nicht dann gehen
jetzt mal wieder auf seinen kanal zurück
um ihr schon mal die kanal info das ist
nämlich eine sache die sehr viele
vergessen haben wir schon mal hier rein
was steht hier der zeit bin ich 15
okay das ist eine sache die auch bei dem
ganzen dingen nicht vergessen darf der
junge ist erst 15
ich will nicht wissen wie ich reagiert
hätte ich als 15 jahre alter besser wenn
ich erst ein video gehabt hätte was 1,7
millionen news bekommt und dann so viele
discs und hey kommentare auf diesem
video
das ist richtig hart ist auch für mich
hat wenn ich viele displays um was es
sich beleidigende kommentare bekommen
und ich bin 21 des 15
generell ich finde diese ganze beleidige
reihe diesen kommentar reviews so
sinnfrei ihr könnt natürlich eure
meinung zu den videos sagen aber leute
beleidigt doch nicht die person auch
wenn es euch nicht gefällt man habt ihr
im leben irgendwas begriff ist vor allem
vollkommen unnötig weil eventuell möchte
man mit diesen kommentar ich auch was
bewirken viel kritik ausüben dass der
andere sich verändert aber mit ihnen
dabei noch beleidigt bloggt er sofort
alles ab aber jetzt schauen wir mal das
video an
das erste was auffällt es ist wirklich
eine krankheit in letzter zeit ja nicht
nur babys beauty palast nicht als
apropos sondern auch gucci hat die mit
roger waters dessen erkrankung die
langsam ganz youtube deutschland
ergreift menschen die gestern noch ganz
normale mitbürger youtuber waren
schalten auf einmal zehn mittel anzeigen
in einem video jetzt mal ohne bis heute
wenn man auf dem video klickt und sowas
schon sieht dann denkt man sich schon so
ist schon mal daumen runter auf jeden
fall wird immer durch wir haben 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9
tatsächlich 10 mid roll anzeigen 10 mit
anzeigen in jedem video was jetzt eine
dokumentation von drei stunden ist sind
scheiße den methoden zeigen in der video
von 25 minuten sind richtig scheiße
ja sobald die vorrede ich hab jetzt
einfach allein zehn minuten geladen
falls video angeschaut habe leute
schauen uns an
ich hoffe ich völlig verquer ist okay
ist
ruhig sitzt wahrscheinlich gerade
einfach einen offenen karton der kartons
wird er schon einfach halb offen in
seinem zimmer im nachhinein so dass die
farbe in dem video bisschen verändert
einem vorprogramm gemacht wenn ihr den
typen auch zugehört leute ihr merkt ihr
wieder redet der ist noch sehr sehr
kindlich ja wenn so eine person also
verhält bekommt das ist einfach mega
bitte auch wenn das video von ihm
relativ dreiste kopie war und natürlich
auch fake genau wie das original das
klar wieso regt das es so auch wer du
bist einfach eine kiste geschrieben die
auf dem fußboden steht und deiner
haustür ist fünf meter entfernt du
kannst aus der kiste raus du versteckst
die selbst mutter post
das funktioniert nicht es ist schon
dreist schauspieler muss man sagen
glaube ich nicht okay leute mal ganz
ehrlich auch wenn er flüstert direkt
danach hat ja angeblich irgendeine
person das paket in der hand bewegt das
hin und her okay ich steht ein meter vor
dem paket okay hier steht das paket
hier steht hier und da wurde mir sagen
dann hört man es nicht auch wenn die mit
in dem paket flüstert das paket ist
nicht schalldicht das bisschen klebeband
außenrum lassen ewig wieder luft
pflücken das hört man doch das ist immer
die beste nummer die typen stehen
angeblich in der postfiliale und lagern
sich ein vom sagt es gibt es nicht
erzählte schild gerade hochgehoben und
person die sie hoch hatte schon ein
paket hochgehoben leute ihr habt das
paket dann so ja euer kopf ist ungefähr
so 40 50 cm von dem tatsächlichen paket
entfernten meter maximal der hört ihr
jedes mucksmäuschen was da drin ist so
akkurat fake ist her
für geräusche das war einfach ein
geräusch von im auto vorbeifährt eine
sache denn ich gedacht als im nachhinein
spiel dargestellt als wäre es echt
nämlich das paket nicht selbstständig
über die straße fahren
das ist keinen sinn macht man in einem
paket eins zu eins den sound ein auto
vorbeifährt pakete über musik sind
normalerweise in einem paket transporter
der selbst ein autor und er hat eine
gewisse isolation außen rum
das heißt wenn er ein auto vorbeifährt
hört man das nicht eins zu eins so
richtig kann normal reden nicht ich weiß
dass für eine scheiße das war ja das war
scheiße idee einfach weil so
offensichtlich ist dass es fähig ist
es ist halt wirklich so offensichtlich
dinger habt ihr mal einen menschen in
paket gepackt hat mir das mal probiert
habt ihr ein versuch mal das paket
hochzuheben die sache ist das gewicht
von den menschen ist so ungleich
verteilt wenn der in dem paket sitzt
sind das so ungefähr 80% einfach am
hintern dass das paket an dieser stelle
mit ultra hoher wahrscheinlichkeit rv
durchbricht wenn man so ein ding
hochgeht dauernd bisher nur papa
dazwischen das bericht jederzeit durch
niemals haters bevor ich mich
verschicken mit 90 kilo
der boden ist gerissen
das wäre tatsächlich ein selbst
verschicken hundertprozentig schon
früher passiert wie gesagt papa von
menschen in paketen versuches paket
hochzuheben um dass der boden durch
reißt keine chance der reis 100% die
gewichtsverteilung ist einfach so
ungleich dass die gewichtsverteilung der
versuchung gleich dass der boden 1000
prozentig reist
[Musik]
okay das ist schon mal die stelle wohl
in lebensgefahr ist und sein kumpel sich
jetzt schnell die klamotten anziehen um
ihn zu retten
warum stellt man noch mal eine kamera
auf wenn der eigene kumpel in
lebensgefahr ist macht es dann auch
zuerst dort kriegt einen anruf von einem
freund so der gleich hat einen
autounfall
ich liege auf der landstraße muss darin
kommen denn das kann ich komm ja ja ich
muss nur noch kurz meine kamera
aufstellen
ach scheiße der akku ist noch nicht
gedacht ich muss noch kurz den akku
laden ich bin so einer halben stunde bei
dir ich denke ich brauche zwei takes für
die aufnahme soll ich nehmen 20 minuten
aufladen vielleicht zehn minuten drüber
ist okay er macht das paket ohne messer
auf sondern erlebt einfach mit der hand
dran das paket geht auf der andere dir
drin ist konnte natürlich nicht er war
ein todesangst aber er hat es nicht
geschafft dieses paket von innen
aufzumachen nicht wird er sich mit aller
kraft mit seinen beiden gegen den deckel
stimmt aber wenn sein kumpel kommen von
außen mit zwei fingern an der haube
ziehen das ding ab macht dann ist etwas
ganz anderes
er hätte nicht von selbst rauskommen
können anders gegangen
gott sei dank hat ihn jemand gerettet
eine kamera aufgestellt gestern 24
stunden sollen
es ist gar nicht so schlecht gespielt
aber diese reaktion passen gar nicht
liegt erst von der kiste so total chaos
dann auf einmal zehn sekunden
[Musik]
okay das war der beste moment des videos
leute das wird das war tatsächlich der
einzige unterhaltsame momente im ganzen
video soll ich tun
nein es war nicht 24 stunden leute okay
leute abschließen was kann man dazu
sagen was korrekt von ihnen das video zu
fällen so zu tun als ob es echt wer nein
was korrekt von ihm das video einfach
dreist von reis kam zu kopieren
nein ist dieses ausmaß an hast dass ein
15-jähriger im internet für so ein video
bekommt angemessen nein ich muss
abschließend sagen leute auch mal zum 3
ist der fake baku sie schauen dich das
video ist ordentlich produziert muss ich
sagen wirklich 25 minuten 43 das ist ein
höllen aufwand dieses video zu machen er
hat mega viele color corrections drauf
er hat sich mit den soundeffekten schon
ordentlich mühe gegeben würde ich sagen
die mir sehr sicher dass es eine menge
arbeit war dass wir zu machen
leider machen halt trotzdem das ist
wirklich fähig ist in diesem sinne
leisten
vielleicht klappt's beim nächsten mal
ich danke fürs duschen zur über das
thema für euch schon ausgerückt war ich
wollte einfach dazu noch ein video
machen bis zum nächsten mal rein macht's
gut